[Music]  once upon a time there was a great war  that brought so much sadness to so many  people hardly anyone could remember what  happiness was like but something  happened that changed all that  [Music]  his name is Christopher Robin but we  generally call him Billy a toast  see our Millions yeah it helped us to  believe in the good things which one  would you like this why they're so high  food good the fun things he's your  favorite  I have to go for the middle one piglet  has to be a piglet and a world full of  imagination  [Music]  all he writes in a book I thought we  were just having fun we're writing a  book and we're having fun  and then just like it's happy turned on  happiness came pouring out  [Music]  [Music]  you